[APPLAUSE]
RYAN GERMICK: Welcome,
everybody.
We are here today with
a bunch movie star
folk, so that's exciting.
SETH ROGEN: We just
got to ride a big
slide, so that's exciting.
We weren't supposed
to, but we did it.
RYAN GERMICK: Did you have
to sign a special waiver?
SETH ROGEN: No, we
just jumped on.
RYAN GERMICK: Wow.
Do your own stunts.
SETH ROGEN: The security
guy did not look
happy, but we did it.
RYAN GERMICK: So we have Seth
Rogen here, Craig Robinson,
Evan Goldberg.
So give another round
of applause here.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH ROGEN: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: So I'm sure you
guys know a lot about these
folks' credits, but I
want to show that I
read IMDB this morning.
SETH ROGEN: Good.
Perfect.
RYAN GERMICK: So you, sir,
are in the new "Arrested
Development."
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, I did a
couple things in that.
RYAN GERMICK: Awesome.
And-- yes.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH ROGEN: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: And then, to
complete the trifecta of
underrated TV shows, also
"Freaks and Geeks,"
"Undeclared."
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, I'm
in all of them.
RYAN GERMICK: Fantastic.
SETH ROGEN: I just wish I was
in "Veronica Mars," and I
could round it out.
RYAN GERMICK: You could
Kickstarter to get yourself
into "Veronica Mars."
SETH ROGEN: I could
get in there.
Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: Cool.
And then you've done
a bunch of stuff.
I'm skipping you for
a second, Craig.
My flow is mixed up.
I apologize.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Happens
all the time.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Tell
me about it.
RYAN GERMICK: We'll come back
to you in about 40 minutes.
And you've done a bunch
of work with Evan--
"Superbad," "Knocked Up,"
"Green Hornet."
SETH ROGEN: Yes.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I tend
to be around.
SETH ROGEN: He's around.
RYAN GERMICK: Yes,
he's around.
But also, you wrote an episode
of "The Simpsons," which I
thought was really cool.
SETH ROGEN: We did write an
episode of "The Simpsons."
EVAN GOLDBERG: It
was thrilling.
RYAN GERMICK: And you were going
"Ali G" when you were,
like, 14 years old.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, we were in
our early 20s, but we were
writers for "The Ali G Show"
when it was on HBO.
I think we were 22 or
23 at the time.
EVAN GOLDBERG: 23, I think.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, it
was a good job.
EVAN GOLDBERG: [INAUDIBLE].
SETH ROGEN: Yeah.
It was fun.
RYAN GERMICK: Craig, you just
wrapped up "The Office."
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yes.
RYAN GERMICK: Like,
119 episodes or
something like that.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG ROBINSON: Oh, no.
It was 200.
The finale made it 200
or 201 or something.
RYAN GERMICK: Wow.
I'm going to--
SETH ROGEN: IMDB got
that one wrong.
RYAN GERMICK: --send
a bug report to--
can't rely on them.
And "Hot Tub Time Machine."
SETH ROGEN: Oh, yeah.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yes, indeed.
SETH ROGEN: They're making
another one.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, I heard
that's your next thing.
CRAIG ROBINSON: "Hot Tub 2" will
start filming on Tuesday.
SETH ROGEN: So exciting.
RYAN GERMICK: It must be tough
to do sequels to movies where
the space-time continuum
is disrupted.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Well, Josh Heald
wrote one, and he wrote
number two.
And it's pretty cool.
SETH ROGEN: It all continues
in a hot tub time universe.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Exactly.
SETH ROGEN: They actually make
most sequels, probably, out of
movies that mess with the
space-time continuum, honestly.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
that's true.
SETH ROGEN: Which makes
the least amount
of sense, but yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: It gives you
a lot of flexibility.
SETH ROGEN: It does.
EVAN GOLDBERG: The ability to
rewrite history in a story
means you can just cheat
as a writer.
SETH ROGEN: Exactly.
You're killing Hitler in
the second one, right?
CRAIG ROBINSON: That's
the goal.
RYAN GERMICK: Good.
If you're not killing Hitler--
SETH ROGEN: That would be
a great plot, though.
RYAN GERMICK: But I want to give
you credit also because
you're in the original "Arrested
Development," like
way back in the day.
So that's pretty cool.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yes, yes.
I was a security guard.
RYAN GERMICK: At
Gengie's house.
CRAIG ROBINSON: And I got to
audition for con man number
two or something.
RYAN GERMICK: And did you
get it over Dr. Funke?
I don't remember how
that wrapped up.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Say again.
RYAN GERMICK: Did you
get the part?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Uh, no.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
RYAN GERMICK: They never
called you back.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Never
called me back.
RYAN GERMICK: Cool.
Well, big movie coming out
this week, June 12.
SETH ROGEN: June 12, yes.
RYAN GERMICK: "This
is the End."
SETH ROGEN: "This is the End."
RYAN GERMICK: So go see it.
Well, that's the point.
That's why they're here.
Not just to ride the slide.
SETH ROGEN: I'm mostly here to
talk about Craig on "Arrested
Development."
RYAN GERMICK: So what was-- no,
so the cast is awesome,
besides the two of you.
Do you make a cameo in
there somewhere?
Are you in the crowd scene?
EVAN GOLDBERG: If you look,
you'll see me somewhere.
RYAN GERMICK: Usually
behind the scenes.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Lurking
around in the back.
RYAN GERMICK: Did you know
like camera was on?
Or was it just like--
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah, Franco came
up to me one day and was
like, you've got to throw
yourself in the background, or
you're going to regret this.
So I did.
RYAN GERMICK: Hitchcock
moment.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I tried to throw
myself in that hellhole,
but I did it with no shirt
because I thought it would be
funny for the crew.
It kind of stood out as
a little weird, so
we had to cut me.
So we threw me in on
another little bit.
RYAN GERMICK: It would be really
disappointing if the
DVD version--
oh, there's beeping.
What's going on?
SETH ROGEN: I don't know.
EVAN GOLDBERG: It's
going to blow.
Throw it in the crowd!
SETH ROGEN: My girlfriend's
about to explode.
RYAN GERMICK: As much as I'm
excited to be here, I'm not
comfortable with this.
If you guys want to use this,
you can film the audience and
the back backstage,
if you'd like.
It's open.
And I think they can flip
to it at some point.
CRAIG ROBINSON: [INAUDIBLE]
going down the slide.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
And you guys got to wear Google
Glass a moment ago.
SETH ROGEN: We did wear
Google Glass.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, that made
this whole trip worth it
immediately.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: It's the
least we could do.
What did you do on
Google Glass?
EVAN GOLDBERG: I thought I
could watch a video, so I
thought I could pull up a
porno to make everyone
uncomfortable.
But it doesn't do video yet.
SETH ROGEN: Doesn't
do that yet.
RYAN GERMICK: They're
working on it.
SETH ROGEN: I honestly
thought we were
coming to YouPorn today.
This was all a horrible
misunderstanding.
RYAN GERMICK: This
is San Bruno.
That's like somewhere
in the valley.
SETH ROGEN: That's in
Chatsworth, I think.
RYAN GERMICK: So "This is the
End" is a bit of a departure
for you guys in that it's like
a religious parable.
SETH ROGEN: Yes.
RYAN GERMICK: It's a very
moralistic tale.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, it's
a moral tale.
Yeah, I think--
I mean, we're always
interested in
that kind of stuff.
I think inherently, it's
interesting to us as people
who weren't raised to believe
that one day the devil is
going to destroy to learn that
a lot of people we know were
raised to think that was
going to happen.
So it was just always something
that kind of
fascinated us, I think.
And we one day just sat
down and thought,
what if they're right?
How would that go?
We'd be fucked.
That's the first thing
I could tell you.
And so that's kind of
where that idea came
from a little bit.
RYAN GERMICK: And is
it a coincidence
that it's in Los Angeles?
Do you think that will be the
epicenter of the apocalypse.
EVAN GOLDBERG: That or Vegas.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, that or
Vegas, or Chatsworth.
RYAN GERMICK: Chatsworth?
EVAN GOLDBERG: Just California,
Southern
California.
RYAN GERMICK: Craig, how did
they pitch this movie to you?
I mean, I figure these guys
are bouncing around-- it
started as a short film.
I want to talk about
it in a second.
But at what point did they
come to you, and how
formulated was the idea?
And how important--
did you get points
on the back end?
Did you have to edit down
the script yourself?
How did that work?
What was your--
CRAIG ROBINSON: No points.
RYAN GERMICK: I'm trying
to speak Hollywood.
I'm doing what--
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, that
was good jargon.
I like that.
RYAN GERMICK: I'm better
with HTML.
CRAIG ROBINSON: The guys, they
just approached me and said,
this is what we're doing.
It's crazy.
And they were explaining
it to me, and we're
going to play ourselves.
And I was just on board, because
it had been a while
since I'd worked with them.
And I know we do good
stuff together.
RYAN GERMICK: Cool.
I agree.
The movie's fun and a
religious parable.
SETH ROGEN: A religious
parable.
RYAN GERMICK: I got the talking
points from Tony.
They wanted me to keep
repeating that.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, I'm sure that
was high on their list.
Make sure you emphasize
the religious aspect.
RYAN GERMICK: Really
emphasize that.
SETH ROGEN: Kids love that.
Speaks to YouTube's audience.
RYAN GERMICK: So I listened
to the Nerdist
podcast you guys did.
And I'm glad that the car ride
here was longer than the part
where it took you to get to
the annoying questions you
always get from every press
type of interview.
SETH ROGEN: Oh, really?
I can't even remember
saying that.
Why, did you have some
of those questions?
RYAN GERMICK: I'd say mostly it
was that, because you said
that for "Guild Trip"--
another film you guys did--
people just wanted to ask you
about Barbra Streisand.
What's Babs like?
That's the whole entire
half of a sheet.
SETH ROGEN: She's great.
RYAN GERMICK: Let's see, I want
to ask-- just taking "The
Guilt Trip" seriously for one
second, because I watched it
on the plane.
I just got back from Chicago.
And I woke up from a nap, and
it was playing on the plane.
This is really two days ago.
And I know in a movie where you
have a romantic partner,
you could potentially
get a girlfriend,
boyfriend jealous, right?
SETH ROGEN: Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, having
Barbra Streisand play your
mom, did that make your
mom jealous at all?
SETH ROGEN: I think it made my
mom psyched, like she was
getting portrayed by who all
Jewish women consider to be
the holy grail of people
portraying them.
It'd be like if Brad Pitt
played me in a movie.
It's be incredibly exciting.
So after being around Barbra
Streisand, you realize every
Jewish woman models themselves
after her, like she's like the
monkey in "Outbreak" that
starts the virus.
If they ever want to cure Jewish
neuroses, she has it in
her DNA somewhere, because
she's the cause of it, I
think, in a lot of ways.
CRAIG ROBINSON: You know that's
going to be a headline.
Seth Rogen compares
Barbra Streisand--
SETH ROGEN: To the "Outbreak"
monkey.
Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: And the sub-line
is like "and cures Jewish
neuroses."
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, and cures
Jewish neuroses.
That'd be good, though.
SETH ROGEN: Plus
one, minus one.
So this film is really
interesting.
I mean, the conceit
it's hilarious.
You guys probably know, you
saw the trailer, the
apocalypse, there's a house
party at James Franco's house.
There's a lot of fancy
Hollywood folks.
Some of them are topless.
Some of them aren't.
Some of them made the cut.
Some of them didn't.
And the apocalypse happens.
Of course, there's a bromance
in there somewhere, as well,
and a group dynamic
that is explored.
But one thing that's really fun
is the meta level of so
many people playing
themselves.
And sometimes, they play against
type, and sometimes
they play with type,
what you'd expect.
Unpack that a little bit.
What's funny about people
commenting on their personas
either in the affirmative
or negative?
EVAN GOLDBERG: Everything's
funny about it.
The actors really went
crazy with it.
They were so excited, as Craig
said earlier, just to do this
weird thing where instead of
performing and then having
everyone comment, they did them
both at the same time.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Another they
did was they took what we
truly wear every day and
made that our wardrobe.
So it was like--
RYAN GERMICK: The "take your
panties off" shirt
that you had on?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yeah, they saw
me with that shirt on at a
party, and they were
like, great.
We want to use that.
SETH ROGEN: And the towel.
He always has a towel.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I always have
a towel, because I'm either
sweating or about to sweat.
RYAN GERMICK: It's a good
place to be in.
CRAIG ROBINSON: So yeah, they
wanted that much reality.
So that part of our characters
is real.
Like when I did the "Take
Your Panties Off"
song, that's real.
I'm playing the piano
stuff from my act.
And then there's other
things that were
just heightened versions--
a movie version where, like--
SETH ROGEN: You wouldn't
let Aziz die.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I wouldn't
I would've at least reached
out for real.
Stuff like that.
RYAN GERMICK: You'd think,
like in the moment--
SETH ROGEN: You don't know.
Yeah.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I mean, but I
was really callous to him.
It's too late for you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RYAN GERMICK: You've got to
establish rules for that.
SETH ROGEN: You would have
pretended that maybe you
would've tried.
CRAIG ROBINSON: No!
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, I mean we've
only been fans of-- like, I
think "Seinfeld" is honestly
one of the
first things I noticed.
My parents were big fans of "The
Garry Shandling Show,"
which was--
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
amazing show.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, which was
amazing, and really kind of--
RYAN GERMICK: And Judd Apatow
connection there.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, but the
original-- like, "Larry
Sanders Show" did it.
But before that, "The Garry
Shandling Show" really was
like a dissected sitcom, like he
was aware of the fact that
he was on a sitcom--
RYAN GERMICK: Go into the
audience, talk to the actors.
SETH ROGEN: In the sitcom, he
would talk to the audience.
And I remember--
I mean, I was a little kid
when that show was on.
But even at that time, I
remember thinking, like, oh
wow, this is really original and
different than "Who's the
Boss" and the other stuff
that was on television.
So I think we were always just
big fans of that type of
slight breaking of the fourth
wall type of comedy.
Charlie Kaufman has done
it very well, I think.
We just made it stupider.
That's the only thing.
SETH ROGEN: So to go a meta
level deeper, in Hollywood--
so I wonder about this in the
software executive world.
When someone goes on stage at a
big conference, do they have
a style consultant that tells
them to wear a black
turtleneck?
I mean, I wonder, because it's
like, is it appealing?
And I wonder, do you guys have--
is there an agent or a
best friend or a girlfriend or
something that tells you, you
should really work this angle.
People like the--
obviously, you're not
really stoners.
So like the stoner--
SETH ROGEN: Exactly.
It's all manufactured for--
EVAN GOLDBERG: No, the reason we
always look so shitty is we
have each other, It's like,
do I look good?
Yeah, sure.
You look fucking great.
SETH ROGEN: That's
the problem.
We're our own terrible
sounding boards.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
EVAN GOLDBERG: Before we came
up here, my wife was like,
you'd better ask the publicist
if you look good.
You're not going to be able to
pull it off on your own.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, it's true.
RYAN GERMICK: They
always tell--
I didn't follow the rule, but
you're not supposed to wear
stripes and checks and stuff
on camera because--
SETH ROGEN: No, you
look good, man.
I think you look good.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, but then
again, I'm not sure if--
SETH ROGEN: He's wearing
checks, too.
It's the blind leading
the blind up here.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, excatly.
It's like a Moire pattern
when it's on screen.
SETH ROGEN: Exactly.
It Moires.
You don't want it to Moire.
RYAN GERMICK: You don't
want a Moire.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RYAN GERMICK: You don't have a
serious conversation with your
agent that's like, you should
work this angle.
That's goes over
well with the--
SETH ROGEN: Not really.
I mean, hopefully the movies
we've done just--
we really try to make the movies
appealing en masse to
the audiences.
So ideally, you can just talk
about the movie for what it
is, and that will do the
manipulation for you.
You don't have to play
up any certain angle.
If you do, it means your movie
probably is not great.
EVAN GOLDBERG: If we worked up
the pot angle, we would just
be "Cheech and Chong," then.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, like I think
we just try to represent the
stuff for what it is and
represent ourselves for how we
are as smart or dumb a strategy
as that may be.
EVAN GOLDBERG: The only thing
we kind of play off of is
wherever we are is what we do.
So we wrote "Superbad" when
we were not getting
laid in high school.
Now we're thinking of doing a
movie where people get engaged
because we both just
got married.
RYAN GERMICK: Congratulations.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We like to do
things that are kind of--
things we relate
to at the time.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, that's the
only thing we try to do.
RYAN GERMICK: So if you did a
movie about coming to YouTube
and getting interviewed, maybe
I could make that Hollywood
transition.
SETH ROGEN: You would.
RYAN GERMICK: Right.
OK.
No laughs.
SETH ROGEN: Who would
play you?
RYAN GERMICK: I don't know.
SETH ROGEN: If not you.
RYAN GERMICK: Juliette Lewis.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, exactly.
Juliette Lewis.
I was going to say Hope Davis.
EVAN GOLDBERG: You got
a big laugh there.
RYAN GERMICK: Craig,
you were being--
she's great in "American
Splendor."
SETH ROGEN: Hope Davis?
Oh yeah, she's great.
RYAN GERMICK: I would
be so proud.
Craig, you were being quiet.
It makes me think that maybe
you do have these
conversations or go a
little bit deeper.
SETH ROGEN: Do you?
RYAN GERMICK: What is the
Craig Robinson persona?
CRAIG ROBINSON: I've had a
stylist and stuff like that.
Yeah, absolutely.
SETH ROGEN: This doesn't
just happen.
CRAIG ROBINSON: This is it.
This is thought out.
I usually have on white
socks, but bam.
Yeah, so--
EVAN GOLDBERG: Also, just your
hair alone gets you into a
whole world of very
calculated--
CRAIG ROBINSON: It opens a
lot of doors, this afro.
RYAN GERMICK: I mentioned
earlier, the movie started as
a short film in,
I think, 2007.
Thank you, IMDB.
Got something right.
At that point, were you thinking
just kind of an idea
that spawned that would
be really fun to do?
Was there larger ambitions
there?
Just walk me through that.
EVAN GOLDBERG: That was a
student film project.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, my buddy went
to USC film school, and
he made it for one
of his projects.
And then we put it on
YouTube, actually.
And it got a lot of attention.
EVAN GOLDBERG: It got,
like, 180,000 hits.
SETH ROGEN: Like very fast.
It's funny, because it was
actually right when "Knocked
Up" was coming out.
We didn't know that people would
in any way be interested
in what we were doing
necessarily.
So it was kind of a pleasant
surprise that we just put this
thing out there, and without
even realizing, expecting it,
it got quite a bit
of attention.
And that's when we started to
think, oh, people actually
like this idea.
Maybe there's something worth
revisiting about it.
RYAN GERMICK: Man, cool.
And then it seems like you guys
get to do a movie with a
lot of your friends,
people you know.
It seems like a lot of fun, but
it's also a lot of work.
I'm kind of curious about--
I know you hate this question,
so I'm not going to ask that
question, what's it like to
work with your friends?
But what's the other side?
What's the hard stuff
about it?
Where does it get stressful?
Do you feel like this,
for example--
I'm going to have a leading
question here.
Do you think the studio looks at
you and says, hey, we gave
you all this money.
You're just screwing around.
You'd better make this movie.
Or is it more like
pretty chill?
EVAN GOLDBERG: We specifically
have worked a situation with
the studio where we're like, how
much money will it be for
you just to never talk to us?
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, basically.
EVAN GOLDBERG: And the answer we
hoped would be $45 million.
Turned out it was $31 million.
SETH ROGEN: But that
was enough.
And honestly, that's what we
really strive for more than
anything is autonomy
and just freedom.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Because with our
comedy, if you don't go
past too far, then you're not
going to have gone far enough.
If they have restraints on us,
they want certain things,
it'll just mess up our style.
SETH ROGEN: And if it's
not really risky--
like I think the movies we've
had the most success with are
the ones where as we're making
them, the whole time, we're
like, this could just
spectacularly go wrong.
Like we literally, conceptually
might have done
something that people
just don't like.
So that actually makes it more
fun, because you feel like
you're really taking a big
swing, and it's a big gamble.
The studio knows how hard
it is to do that.
They make a lot of movies that
sometimes aren't as funny as
they hoped they would be.
So I think they appreciate when
people actually are able
to make an audience
laugh a lot.
And they put a lot in that.
And they don't often pretend
they know how to do that
better than we do,
which is nice.
RYAN GERMICK: I forgot to
introduce myself, but it's
related to this point.
I'm Ryan Germick.
I lead the Google Doodle team.
That's what I do, usually.
And so I'm usually
not on YouTube.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Oh,
Google Doodle.
Whoa.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH ROGEN: What is Hope Davis
doing the head of--
RYAN GERMICK: And we have a
similar philosophy where if
you're not breaking something,
you're probably not trying
hard enough.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, definitely.
It needs to be almost a terrible
idea in order to be a
really good idea.
CRAIG ROBINSON: These guys,
they mix these genres, so
they're becoming--
like "Pineapple Express" mixed
stoner with this action,
bloody stuff.
And this one is apocalyptic with
comedy with supernatural
things going on.
They're carving out
this niche.
It's pretty special.
RYAN GERMICK: I agree.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Thank
you, Craig.
RYAN GERMICK: It looks like
a $45 million movie.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, it does.
Looks like we got
what we wanted.
RYAN GERMICK: This is also a
foray into directing for you,
which is unusual, right, Seth?
Like you're--
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, we've
never directed
anything before, literally.
RYAN GERMICK: So how was that?
How is that process different
from-- usually, you're very
involved as a writer,
producer.
But director is kind
of another step.
So what's up with that?
SETH ROGEN: It's a lot
of fun, honestly.
Producing--
we keep saying--
directors are going
to hate us.
Producing a movie is a lot
harder than directing a movie.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Like
10 times harder.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, like getting
people to give you $31 million
is way harder than spending
$31 million.
It's fun to spend $31 million.
It takes years to convince
people to give you that money.
EVAN GOLDBERG: And as the
writer, you're always
answering to people.
As the producer, you're always
As the director, everyone
answers to you, and you just
get to have the fun.
SETH ROGEN: It's true.
It was kind of a revelation.
We were like, oh, wow.
This is way more fun than the
other jobs we've been doing.
So yeah, it was great.
And in some ways, it was less
stressful than not directing
the movie, because as the
producer, we didn't have to
worry about what stupid shit the
director might do, because
we were the ones doing
the stupid shit.
RYAN GERMICK: Craig, how'd
they do as directors?
CRAIG ROBINSON: They
were great.
It was like being in the
basement with your friends,
and somebody's like,
I got a camera.
And then let's do some
funny stuff.
RYAN GERMICK: Did you realize
they were making
a film at the time?
CRAIG ROBINSON: I was
like, wait a minute.
Is this a set?
But it was a lot of fun.
And they took liberties.
Like there was a drug sequence
in the film.
And this didn't make the film,
but we recreated a Spider-Man
kind of thing, where Franco was
The Goblin, and he was on
a skateboard.
EVAN GOLDBERG: And we got
his mask and shit.
CRAIG ROBINSON: And Seth
was pushing him around.
And he was goblining, and
McBride was Spider-Man.
And I was behind him.
I was Mary Jane.
So yeah, we did these things.
SETH ROGEN: Craig
was in a wig.
CRAIG ROBINSON: A blond wig--
SETH ROGEN: He had
lipstick on.
CRAIG ROBINSON: --and
red lipstick.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Screaming,
help me, Spider-Man!
Save me!
RYAN GERMICK: So the cast--
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yeah,
that happened.
SETH ROGEN: It's
fun to direct.
RYAN GERMICK: Do you think
they'll just give you-- how
many millions can you get to
just put that out directly as
an entire feature film?
EVAN GOLDBERG: Depends
how cool Marvel is.
SETH ROGEN: I think we need
Marvel's permission for that.
EVAN GOLDBERG: They're pretty
easy going, I hear.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yeah, I hear
they're cool with ecstasy use
in their characters.
RYAN GERMICK: So amazing
cast to mention.
You guys, Jay Baruchel, Danny
McBride, Jonah Hill, Emma
Watson, James Franco, Michael
Cera, Aziz Ansari, Rihanna.
There's like a million funny,
interesting people.
Who surprised you the most on
set as far as how far they
were willing to go with
lampooning themselves?
Or any diva moments?
CRAIG ROBINSON: That's
a spoiler alert,
that one, isn't it?
RYAN GERMICK: Well, yeah.
So without the spoiler.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We
didn't really--
SETH ROGEN: Michael Cera.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I'd have
to say Michael Cera.
SETH ROGEN: There's some cameos
in the movie that
actually aren't revealed in any
capacity, I think, that
people will be shocked to see.
And we'd like to keep
it that way.
But Michael Cera, everyone
knows he's in the movie.
And what he did was
unbelievable.
He plays a coked-out sexual
deviant, which the real
Michael Cera hasn't
been for years.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I think he
might still be a virgin.
SETH ROGEN: So yeah, it was
pretty amazing to see him do
that, because it was actually
scary at times.
It got dark at times.
EVAN GOLDBERG: It's crazy when
you have, like, 16 incredible
actors all watching him,
going, holy shit.
This guy is going for it.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, everyone was
like, I can't believe he's
doing this.
Yeah, it was pretty
unbelievable.
EVAN GOLDBERG: He got
a lot standing
ovations from the crew.
SETH ROGEN: They don't give out
Oscars for that type of
performance, but they
should consider it.
RYAN GERMICK: So it got dark.
So is that stuff that
went off script?
Did you guys do a lot of
improv on the set?
How do you manage
that versus--
as a director and writer, you
probably have some feeling of
preciousness about
what you wrote.
SETH ROGEN: Not at all.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We create the
structure-- like literally, if
Craig figured out a better
ending while we were filming
it, we would have done that.
SETH ROGEN: Like Franco kind
of came up with the end for
his character.
We actually had another thing.
And it was something he pitched,
and we were like,
yeah, we could do that.
I mean, we really--
EVAN GOLDBERG: We can't deny
that all these guys, some of
them are better at our jobs
than we are in certain
capacities.
Like Franco's directed way more
stuff than we ever had at
that point.
And so we let them come in
and do what they can.
And in the end, we think this
one was about 50-50.
SETH ROGEN: The best
idea wins.
CRAIG ROBINSON: There's a
lot of playfulness, too.
Yeah, there's a structure.
You've got the script
there and the set.
And then you just--
you know you've got to
hit these beats.
So you start to play
around it.
But every scene, we got
to play in there.
And it's always--
the in-the-moment stuff
usually wins.
RYAN GERMICK: How do
you plan for play?
I mean, you're on a tight
schedule, right?
You've got so much money.
You've got so much time.
You kind of estimate this
shot's going to take
this long to shoot.
But then do you put in, like,
x amount of buffer to say,
we're going to screw around
a little bit, too?
EVAN GOLDBERG: Our first AD,
Jonathan Watson, might be the
greatest AD to ever live.
And he just assessed how we
worked and figured it out.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, he'd worked
with us before.
He did "Eastbound & Down,"
also, which they do a
lot of improv on.
And he would ask us sometimes.
Sometimes, we would tell him.
We would be like, this scene,
we know we're going to
really go off on.
And I think he was actually
really great at just kind of
gauging on his own by who was in
the scenes and how many of
us were in them as to how
long we needed to shoot.
And we finished right
on schedule.
EVAN GOLDBERG: But every blue
moon, like the Milky Way food
scene, we did it.
And then we came up with this
thing where Jonah had the gun.
And so we had to go back and
redo all the coverage of Seth,
because we didn't know the gun
thing then, because we hadn't
figured it out yet.
So that happened a few times.
And when that happens, you can
get fucked over, because you
have a very small amount of time
in the day, and you have
to spend an extra 45 minutes
catching things because one
person just said one thing, and
it sent/ the whole thing
in another direction.
SETH ROGEN: Sometimes, it's so
funny, you're just like, oh,
we've got to go back and cover
it on the other guys.
Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, Jonah
Hill was really amazing.
He did an awesome job
in this movie.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, he has a super
bizarre performance.
RYAN GERMICK: He was one of
the only people who played
super nice [INAUDIBLE].
SETH ROGEN: Super nice.
Yeah, that was his
idea, actually.
And that kind of speaks to how
we developed the characters
with the guys.
Like at first, we kind of knew
where we wanted his story to
end, which I won't ruin.
But it's pretty--
RYAN GERMICK: It's a dark,
ridiculous-- yeah.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, it ends
in a pretty dark way.
So we kind of worked backward
from there.
And at first, we wrote his
character as being kind of
like an aggressive asshole.
And it was actually his idea.
It was like, I think it's more
interesting if I'm one of
those guys who acts super nice,
and you can't really
tell if I'm an asshole or not.
And some people think I am, and
some people think I'm not.
And it just turned into this
really bizarre performance.
And he wears this giant diamond
earring, which is so strange.
EVAN GOLDBERG: And there's
literally--
he was just like, I would
like to wear a
giant diamond earring.
SETH ROGEN: We almost talked him
into actually piercing his
ear, which would've
been hilarious.
EVAN GOLDBERG: He should've.
We lost a lot of time with
that thing falling off.
SETH ROGEN: It's true.
It kept falling off.
We were like, ah, just
pierce it, dude.
Yeah, I mean, the actors really
seemed to take some
kind of masochistic
joy in making
themselves look terrible.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Jay said to me
in the middle of it, he was
just like, this is crazy.
He's like, I'm at work, I'm
getting a paycheck, and I'm
having free therapy.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, it's kind
of like therapy, because you
have actors, like Daniel Day
Lewis, like transform.
But this is like an inward--
SETH ROGEN: Exactly.
That's the real hard
place to look.
[INAUDIBLE] looking
at yourself.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Michael Cera was
Daniel Day Lewis-esque.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
I think so.
I saw that.
So there's definitely a running
theme of bromance in
your guys' work, to
use a phrase.
Or just sort of male
camaraderie.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I'd much prefer
if the world took male
camaraderie instead
of bromance.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, exactly.
RYAN GERMICK: Sick
of bromance?
Sick of that?
You mentioned earlier you guys
are writing and making movies
that are kind of like
where you're at.
Is that something you think
you'll continue to work at?
What's interesting about male
camaraderie to you in a
narrative sense?
SETH ROGEN: For one thing, it
just seems to be something
that, until more recently, not
a lot of movies were about
that as much.
Almost every comedy had some
sort of romantic story in it.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Studios were
like, and the woman character?
Who's the love interest?
SETH ROGEN: Like "Ghostbusters,"
I
mean, all of them.
It's kind of like, and then
there's this romantic story.
RYAN GERMICK: Though it's pretty
cool when Sigourney
Weaver is like floating--
SETH ROGEN: No, it's a great.
And I'm not saying it's bad.
I'm just saying--
EVAN GOLDBERG: That's literally
probably our
favorite movie.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, it's probably
our favorite movie.
But it just became such a
convention that it almost
started to feel obligatory,
whether or not it was organic
to the story you were trying
to tell or not.
And often, we just found that
our movies, what we were
tending to write about, what
we were experiencing, was
these kind of relationships that
we were having with other
guys, not with women.
And again, there are just so
many romantic comedies out
there that I think we also feel
like we didn't have a lot
to offer that genre.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Like during the
earlier years of our lives, we
dated girls, and
they moved on.
But our friends did not.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, exactly.
EVAN GOLDBERG: And now
we're married.
So who knows?
Maybe we'll write some hilarious
marriage comedies.
But until now, we've been a
bunch of guys with girls who
come and go in our lives, but
the guys stay the same.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, and that seems
to be where the real
stories in our lives have felt
like they've come from.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I also think that
women, in general, can
work with really, really
handsome men
whenever they want.
We're just not--
SETH ROGEN: They just don't
want to work with us.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Who would want
to stand around with these
three guys all day when you
could be with Ben Affleck?
SETH ROGEN: Exactly.
RYAN GERMICK: Like, Natalie,
I've got this
story idea for you.
SETH ROGEN: Just aesthetically,
there's better
places to be.
RYAN GERMICK: Craig, what kind
of movies would you like that
aren't out there?
CRAIG ROBINSON: What kind of
movies would I like to see?
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
These guys mentioned that they
saw the male camaraderie
dearth in Hollywood, and they're
filling that role.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Well, you're
big into dragon movies.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I was
in a dragon movie.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Craig's in a
Korean movie called "Dragon
Wars" that everyone
should check out.
SETH ROGEN: It's dope.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I like
all that stuff, man.
I like gangster comedies.
Yeah, a gangster comedy.
That would be fun.
EVAN GOLDBERG: You
want to make one?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yeah.
EVAN GOLDBERG: OK.
SETH ROGEN: Like "Boyz n
the Hood" but funny?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yeah.
See, another genre twist.
SETH ROGEN: "Don't be a Menace
to South Central While
Drinking Your Juice
in the Hood."
EVAN GOLDBERG: That
was a great movie.
CRAIG ROBINSON: That
was very funny.
SETH ROGEN: Wayans brothers.
RYAN GERMICK: So at YouTube,
I mean, I have to ask--
I know you guys have
had amazing--
it's an honor to be
with you guys.
You've got amazing success
doing your thing.
It's really cool.
At YouTube, I'm wondering, even
though you found this
huge success in the Hollywood
system, what do you think new
media has to offer, distribution
on the internet,
that kind of thing?
Do you look at that as a
place for possibility?
Are you worried about
the kids coming up?
They're going to take
your jobs, or what's
the story with that?
SETH ROGEN: Yeah.
It's interesting, honestly.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We're learning.
SETH ROGEN: We're learning
about it.
We, honestly, are a little older
than I think a lot of
the people who are kind
of on the forefront
of this stuff are.
But it is--
I mean, I do like the kind of
Darwinistic, slash, kind of
democratic nature of YouTube,
how anyone can put
anything out there.
And just what people
like is the stuff
that people will watch.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We're from
a socialist country.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, exactly.
We like that.
Yeah, as Canadians, we approve
of that mentality.
But honestly, it is just--
like we have friends that are
a lot better at it than we
are, honestly.
Like the Lonely Island guys are
brilliant with this stuff.
And Sarah Silverman's really
great with it.
So honestly, we're not by any
means the guys who are using
this to the best of
its potential.
EVAN GOLDBERG: But we do
understand the potential's
massive and is the future.
And if we don't figure
it out, we're fucked.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, exactly.
So that's why we came
here today, and to
ride the slide, mostly.
But that's the other reason.
CRAIG ROBINSON: It's amazing.
It's launching careers
and all of that.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, man.
We've hired people--
CRAIG ROBINSON: Because it
levels the playing field.
SETH ROGEN: --off YouTube,
basically, like Bo Burnham.
We first saw his stuff
on YouTube.
There's a lot of guys
who we saw--
Gerard Carmichael.
I think we first were shown
his stand up on--
I mean, it's just a way
that people just,
hey, check this out.
And we've literally put these
people in movies and stuff
like that based on it.
So for us, it's helpful just as
people who are looking for
funny people to exploit.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah,
this movie--
"This is the End" would not have
happened if it wasn't for
YouTube because we
made the short.
It wasn't quite good enough.
It was about eight
minutes long.
So Jason Stone, who directed
the short, reduced it to a
minute and a half trailer.
And every now and then, someone
would be like, oh, I
watched that.
And it would remind
us of the movie.
And it kept it in the forefronts
of our minds.
And it wasn't for that, it
would've just been a short.
Move on.
We would have never thought
of it again, probably.
RYAN GERMICK: So there's a mic
in the center of the room.
There's a lot of YouTube folks
here that might have some
insightful questions
and comments.
If you guys want to line up--
we'll keep jabbering, but if
you have questions--
SETH ROGEN: Could be about
anything, guys.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Come
on, YouTubers.
SETH ROGEN: Our clothes
or our meal
preferences for the afternoon.
RYAN GERMICK: And while that's
happening, if it happens--
there's crickets
back out there.
SETH ROGEN: I know.
No one?
Someone will start, and then
slowly, more people will--
[CHEERING}
EVAN GOLDBERG: There you go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH ROGEN: We've seen
how it goes.
EVAN GOLDBERG: You can
ask two questions.
Anything you want.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, this guy
gets a bonus question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have two questions, and
they're both for Craig.
SETH ROGEN: Nice.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Nice.
Good pick.
AUDIENCE: Craig, how long have
you been playing piano?
And follow up, do you have any
tips on how to get sexy?
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG ROBINSON: Playing
piano since really--
my mother plays.
It's in my blood.
It's in all her children's
blood.
SETH ROGEN: Was she
a piano teacher?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Well,
she taught piano.
She taught choir.
And I followed her footsteps
for a while.
I was a music teacher
in Chicago.
But yeah, since I was in the
womb, I swear, man, I've been
playing since I can remember.
RYAN GERMICK: It's weird to go
from the womb to your mother
to getting sexy.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CRAIG ROBINSON: It's not weird.
Watch.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Have you ever
done a family act?
Has your family ever
performed together?
You're all musical.
CRAIG ROBINSON: At church.
At church, we would
perform together.
So yeah, that was that.
As far as getting sexy--
RYAN GERMICK: He goes for it.
CRAIG ROBINSON: --be
yourself, man.
Be yourself.
Own all that you are.
Own it, be confident in
it, and be like yeah,
this is what's up.
But you ain't got to be arrogant
about it, neither.
SETH ROGEN: Just keep the
sweat towel handy.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yeah,
keep a sweat towel.
Always, baby.
Yeah, you know what
I'm saying?
EVAN GOLDBERG: I've
got to say, you're
just starting to sweat.
You lasted a long time.
SETH ROGEN: You've held
out really well.
CRAIG ROBINSON: You should've
seen me on the slide.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering what
all of your special foods are.
SETH ROGEN: Our special foods?
RYAN GERMICK: Like your
happy place foods?
AUDIENCE: Your happy
place food.
Yeah.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Mine's a drink.
Blue Powerade.
SETH ROGEN: He does love
Mountain Berry Blast.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Mountain
Berry Blast.
It's kind of salty and sweet.
And after a night of drinking,
there's nothing better than a
blue Powerade.
If you haven't tried
it, try it.
SETH ROGEN: It tastes
exactly how real
mountain berries taste.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Once
they're blasted.
SETH ROGEN: Once they're
blasted.
Yeah.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Every morning, I
take orange juice, and I mix
all these super foods
in there and do a
little super food smoothie.
That's my most consistent thing
I like to drink that I
probably wouldn't drink
five years ago.
But now I'm all about them.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Because you're
mature with your food.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I'm maturing.
SETH ROGEN: I like
cheeseburgers.
I eat those a lot.
CRAIG ROBINSON: They
are delicious.
SETH ROGEN: Herb's Burgers!
EVAN GOLDBERG: Herb's Burgers.
If you ever go to LA, go
to Herb's Burgers.
Have Mountain Berry Blast.
Have a great time.
SETH ROGEN: And a smoothie.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Christine,
and I'm an intern here.
And I was just wondering what
your first jobs were.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Seth and I, for
$10 for two hours plus a large
pizza, flyered for Domino's.
SETH ROGEN: We did.
RYAN GERMICK: Wow.
Is that legal?
EVAN GOLDBERG: And we would take
the flyers, put them on
the cars around the Domino's,
then throw them in a dumpster,
go hang out in an alley and read
comic books, then eat our
pizza and take our $10.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah.
I did that a couple times.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Oh, and we spun
the signs sometimes.
SETH ROGEN: I never did that.
You and Fogell did that.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Wow.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We were harder
workers than you.
SETH ROGEN: The actual--
I wrote jokes for a mohel,
who is the guy that does
circumcisions in the
Jewish community.
I did stand up when I was in
high school, and a mohel saw
me perform.
And he came to me after, and he
was like, I want my mohel
service to be funnier.
Could you write me some jokes?
And he paid me pretty well.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Do you remember
any of the jokes?
SETH ROGEN: They were
all like bad puns.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Do you
remember any--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RYAN GERMICK: We'll
give you a minute.
We can come back to it.
SETH ROGEN: There was some
knife fight jokes.
I survived the knife fight.
RYAN GERMICK: How would you
feel, I mean, if you found out
that Seth Rogen had written
some of your
circumcision jokes?
SETH ROGEN: Some of
your mohel jokes?
Yeah, that would be
exciting, I think.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I'm sure
the mohel's aware.
SETH ROGEN: I don't know why
he thought he wanted people
laughing and stuff like that.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah, you want
people steady and calm.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, exactly.
No one fucking breathe.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I was--
I don't even know what
the title is.
I worked in a law firm.
SETH ROGEN: Lawyer.
It's called a lawyer.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I would make
copies and run and get bagels.
I was a gofer or whatever.
EVAN GOLDBERG: You
were an intern.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Not
even an intern.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Below
intern is gofer?
CRAIG ROBINSON: I would
just do things for
people at the law firm.
I remember this one lawyer,
he called me Clay.
He never learned my name.
Thanks a lot, Clay.
It was like, oh.
And I also remember, I was
carrying $1.5 million checks.
And I would be walking down the
street like, oh my god!
Oh my god!
Better not lose that, Clay!
SETH ROGEN: Don't lose
that check, Clay.
RYAN GERMICK: Signs all over
the city looking for Clay.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah,
where's Clay?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: This question's
for Clay--
I mean, Craig.
How did you get involved in
the "Dragon Wars" movie?
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah,
more "Dragon Wars."
AUDIENCE: Somebody had to ask.
RYAN GERMICK: Probably like 90%
of the people here have
seen this movie.
SETH ROGEN: Have you
seen "Dragon Wars?"
EVAN GOLDBERG: Can we
see a show of hands?
AUDIENCE: Actually--
kind of funny story--
I walked into it because I was
really early or really late
for a movie, something
like that.
I kind of walked and sat in
there, and I was like--
I was kind of in shock that it
actually became a movie.
I mean, it was great.
It was amazing.
I think it's very underrated.
But I'm just kind of--
I didn't even, honestly, until
I just looked back now,
realize that you were in it.
But how did you get involved
in such a random movie?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Wait, so
you saw it for free.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CRAIG ROBINSON: I was in a TV
show called "Lucky" on FX.
And the casting director brought
me over to "Dragon
Wars." They sent me this
trailer of this crazy--
these Korean War fighting
in these dragons
and shit and snakes.
It was amazing.
It was like, Craig, you want
to be in this movie?
What?
Yes!
How?
So she brought me
in the audition.
I got the part.
And the Korean director is a
guy named Hyung-rae Shim.
He is a big-time comedian
and legend in Korea.
And he was directing now, and he
spoke very little English.
And only thing I really
understood
him say was, action!
So he would say that.
And then, like in the
movies we do, they
let the cameras roll.
Or they're like, cut.
Let's try it again.
You do five, six, who knows
how many it takes.
This dude did two takes.
And I would be like, OK,
I'm going to set up.
We'll do it again.
They're like, OK, moving on.
What?
Ah!
No!
So yeah, thanks for
bringing that up.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
That's all I had to ask.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys.
First off, Evan, Seth,
shabbat shalom.
SETH ROGEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Shabbat shalom.
Craig, you too.
Shabbat shalom.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Hey, man.
I went to Israel for
birthrights.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just curious.
In the movie, which of the
characters shows the most
glimpses of them being exactly
like they are in real life.
I really hope it's Jonah Hill.
EVAN GOLDBERG: It
is Seth and Jay.
They just play super, super
stupid, less moral versions of
themselves.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I think that
cheeseburger scene is as real
as it gets.
You bite into that--
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah,
you're right.
That is the most real moment.
The first 10 minutes
are almost totally
realistic to life.
SETH ROGEN: So yeah, we kind of
anchor the movie slightly.
Whatever anchor there is,
I think we provide.
So yeah, I think me and Jay are
probably the closest to
our characters.
AUDIENCE: Nice, nice.
CRAIG ROBINSON: And then when
I sing "Take Your Panties
Off," that's real.
EVAN GOLDBERG: That's some
Craig Robinson shit.
AUDIENCE: It felt real.
It felt very real.
Thanks, guys.
SETH ROGEN: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: So we have
a few questions
from Twitter as well.
SETH ROGEN: Great.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Hello,
Twitter.
EVAN GOLDBERG: I assumed we were
not to mention Twitter
while we were here.
RYAN GERMICK: They
bleep it out.
SETH ROGEN: It's a symbiotic
relationship.
RYAN GERMICK: It's like,
Google+ questions.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH ROGEN: Gmail had
a few questions.
RYAN GERMICK: This is from--
this is all capitals.
I don't how this works out.
EVAN GOLDBERG: You've
got to say it loud.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, no, their
name is all capitals.
SRV_JR asks-- this is
for you, Seth, but I
think everybody can--
what's your favorite movie that
you've been in so far?
I guess it's, like, I don't
know, favorite-- just
qualitatively and maybe
aesthetically fulfilling.
I don't know.
CRAIG ROBINSON: "Dragon Wars."
SETH ROGEN: "Dragon
Wars." Yeah.
It's tough.
I don't know.
I really like "Observe and
Report," honestly.
It's a totally insane movie.
It's one of those movies--
I mean, I like this movie,
too, obviously.
But I feel--
EVAN GOLDBERG: You should've
said "This is the End," Seth.
SETH ROGEN: I don't want to say
one of my own movies that
I wrote and directed.
So I'll give Jody Hill some
credit. "Observe and Report."
Let's do that.
Evan?
EVAN GOLDBERG: I like
"Pineapple Express."
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
that was awesome.
EVAN GOLDBERG: It's just, I
can re-watch it again and
again, and it doesn't
make me bored.
And most of the other movies,
I'd rather blow my brains out
than watch them again,
because I've seen
them all 5,000 times.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, I remember I
heard you guys say-- and you
said, Seth, in the podcast you
never listen to or watch one
minute or one second of any
of the press, Seth,
that you've ever done.
SETH ROGEN: No.
RYAN GERMICK: So do you think
you'll be, like, 80 years old
and all this stuff will probably
just live on forever
somewhere, and going down memory
lane and jogging--
SETH ROGEN: Watch myself
do press junkets.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, what do you
want to say to yourself 50
years from now?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Nice.
SETH ROGEN: Nice.
What do you want to
say, Craiggers?
CRAIG ROBINSON: No, you first.
SETH ROGEN: I don't know.
Hang in there, pal.
If you're alive, then it's
a fucking miracle.
That's what i want to say.
It means you're 81, which
is pretty good.
RYAN GERMICK: Craig, do
you watch this stuff?
When you do press stuff, do
you ever go back and give
yourself notes?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Eh.
RYAN GERMICK: Little bit?
CRAIG ROBINSON: Very little--
I mean, not much nowadays.
Matter of fact, no.
I used to kind of see
stuff when it
first started happening.
And then it gets twisted.
Like I've read some articles
where it's
not even how I talk.
And they twisted to
the words all up.
RYAN GERMICK: Like old
English or something.
CRAIG ROBINSON: What is
really going on here?
I did not say that.
SETH ROGEN: I don't
use the word "ye."
CRAIG ROBINSON: So yeah,
I don't do that.
I just started watching
myself on screen.
So I don't do that as much.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Seth and
I have a good time.
Every now and then, we'll go
onto IMDB under my name.
It just says Evan Goldberg.
And we directly shit talk back
to people who shit talk us.
We haven't done it in years,
but that used to be fun.
Just tackle the bad
press dead on.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah.
Antagonize people,
RYAN GERMICK: But it's just the
lowly commenters, right?
You don't actually
get to the--
the actual people writing
reviews, do you ever get to--
SETH ROGEN: On Twitter, I
respond to actual movie
critics and stuff like that.
EVAN GOLDBERG: What is it?
Something called The Playlist
just said something
bad about our movie.
So I said, you've broken
our hearts.
We tried really hard, and you've
hurt our feelings.
SETH ROGEN: It's true.
We play the emotional card.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Because if we're
like, fuck you, asshole,
you guys suck--
RYAN GERMICK: It just
fuels the fire.
EVAN GOLDBERG: --they're going
to be like, well, fuck you!
SETH ROGEN: We're just
like, why, man?
We tried so hard.
I don't criticize the work
you try really hard on.
I support it in the hopes that
it will improve one day.
RYAN GERMICK: This should be--
I don't know if you can
use Tangicon's tweet
in your movie promotion.
But it's a little bit
of a softball.
Would you consider this
the "Avengers" of
comedy, this film?
EVAN GOLDBERG: We said that
all the time on set.
We hope.
I know it won't make the
same amount of money.
But you know that shot in
"Avengers" where they go
around all of them, and they're
standing in a circle?
We tried that.
We failed, because we're
shittier directors.
But we had that same
shot in our movie.
SETH ROGEN: We had no
robots, though.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We talked a lot
about how in "Avengers," when
all of them were together, was
the best part of the movie.
And that kind of led us to try
to keep all six of our guys
together for every scene
that we could.
RYAN GERMICK: I'm curious.
What do you guys-- what's
your relationship--
we talked a little about
YouTube, but relationship to
technology, in general.
You're sort of a nerd heaven
right now in Silicon Valley.
You guys live down south,
presumably.
SETH ROGEN: We do.
RYAN GERMICK: What gets you
excited about being up here?
Is there anything about
the future technology?
EVAN GOLDBERG: You guys
have dim sum that's
years ahead of ours.
SETH ROGEN: It just makes us
realize how shitty all our
offices are more
than anything.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah, we had
"Rock Band," and we thought
that made us cool.
SETH ROGEN: Oh, we
got an Xbox.
Yeah.
Twitter, they're like, we got
"Dance Dance Revolution." We
don't have that.
Honestly, as far as promoting
the movies go, it's really
interesting, because I've seen
just in the years I've been
making movies a real shift as to
where the attention you get
is, where it comes from, and
how to communicate with the
people who are doing it and how
to just get the message of
your movie out there.
It used to be about doing press
junkets where you talk
to "Access Hollywood" and
"Entertainment Tonight."
And now we still
do that stuff.
I don't know if it's useful
or not, but we do.
But to me, this kind of stuff
is really the type of thing
that seems like it's going in
the direction of where the
stuff will be going more.
People spend a lot
more time online.
The regular peoples' opinions,
I think, infiltrate the
marketplace a lot more with
Twitter and Facebook
and stuff like that.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Which
is way less boring,
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, which is kind
of better in a lot of
ways, because honestly, that's
who we make movies for.
Often, people in the film
community are actually the
last people that we are making
these movies for.
We're making them for people
who are far from that.
And so it's actually--
it's really amazing, and it's
cool just to come to these
companies and see--
I mean, these are some of the
biggest, most successful, new,
young companies on the planet.
So it's just neat seeing, just
on a visceral level, how they
work on a day-to-day basis.
CRAIG ROBINSON: And
it's so much--
I'm addicted to the
technology.
All the sites, like Facebook
and YouTube and--
I don't even know what
else is out there.
So a girl came up to
me the other day,
you're not on Tumblr?
And I'm like, what?
I don't even know what--
why?
Is it--
RYAN GERMICK: You guys have to
bleep all these out, right?
CRAIG ROBINSON: You're
not on Google+?
But it all comes down to
the human part, like we
were doing a tour.
And I guess you all got the
slide here and then the sleep
chair, right?
Who's been in the nap chair?
Come on.
Yeah?
EVAN GOLDBERG: I thought it'd
be like a shame thing, where
no one ever uses it.
RYAN GERMICK: You have
to book it, I think.
I think you can reserve it.
CRAIG ROBINSON: But
they said that--
SETH ROGEN: I think the security
guard kicked you out
of the nap chair.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Oh, he's getting
in the crowd now.
Who's been in the nap chair?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CRAIG ROBINSON: --now
the camera's on you.
But they were saying that you
all believe the best ideas
come between sleep and being
awake, like that moment.
So that was really interesting
to me.
So I will have to start--
RYAN GERMICK: Napping more?
CRAIG ROBINSON: --keeping a
Dictaphone near my bed.
Yes, I said Dictaphone.
You all don't even know
what that is.
SETH ROGEN: They'll replace that
with Google [INAUDIBLE].
The Google Chrome.
RYAN GERMICK: What
about you, Evan?
What does Silicon Valley
do for you?
What's going on in technology
that you're excited about?
Or disappointed in?
I mean, what could
we do better?
EVAN GOLDBERG: I don't know.
They kind of covered all
the things that are
out there right now.
RYAN GERMICK: Dictaphone was
on the tip of your tongue?
SETH ROGEN: You guys
seen Dictaphones?
EVAN GOLDBERG: Smaller
Dictaphones.
Smaller Dictaphones.
RYAN GERMICK: Less intimidating
Dictaphones.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Dictaphone
glasses.
RYAN GERMICK: So what's
next for you guys?
You guys, you got married.
EVAN GOLDBERG: We got
married, yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: How long is it
going to take you to process
the marriage stuff until
you've got a
movie out of that?
EVAN GOLDBERG: We both should've
proposed about a
year or two earlier
than we did, so--
SETH ROGEN: We've had a
long time to process
this marriage stuff.
We started writing a movie--
yeah, we started kind of kicking
around an idea about
people getting married
and engagement and
that type of stuff.
So yeah, there's usually a
couple-year gestation period,
I guess, that it takes.
But yeah, we've started
kicking it around.
EVAN GOLDBERG: And we just
finished filming a movie
that's kind of on the same
point, the next step in our
maturing, which is--
SETH ROGEN: I play a father.
EVAN GOLDBERG: He's
a father with Rose
Byrne, who's his wife.
And they have a six month--
year old daughter.
And Zac Efron moves in next
door with his frat.
And they go to war.
So we're literally bridging our
generational gap ourselves
through our movies.
It's all free therapy.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, exactly.
It sounds good.
Craig, what about you?
EVAN GOLDBERG: "Dragon
Wars 2."
CRAIG ROBINSON: "Dragon
Wars" 2 and 3.
I've got a movie coming out June
7, Friday before "This is
the End." It's called
"Rapture-Palooza." It's set
two years into the rapture--
SETH ROGEN: You have two rapture
movies [INAUDIBLE].
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yeah,
two apocalyptic
movies five days apart.
RYAN GERMICK: That's a
great double feature.
SETH ROGEN: It is.
RYAN GERMICK: Kind of
a bummer, but--
CRAIG ROBINSON: And
the Antichrist has
taken over the world.
And I play the Antichrist.
Yep.
SETH ROGEN: I see that.
CRAIG ROBINSON: And I fall in
love with Anna Kendrick and
really want to sleep with her.
And then hilarity ensues.
SETH ROGEN: The physicality of
that leaves many questions.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CRAIG ROBINSON: Wait until
you see the poster.
RYAN GERMICK: So this movie
comes out in two weeks?
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, like
a week and a half.
RYAN GERMICK: So sell it.
Why should people go
out and rush to the
theater to see this film?
SETH ROGEN: I mean,
it's so much less
meaningful coming from us.
Did you like it?
RYAN GERMICK: I liked it.
I love the meta stuff, so like
the Larry Sanders stuff.
And I would want to--
we were talking earlier--
like, drill deeper.
I want to see you talking with
your agent about, we're going
to make this movie
about ourselves.
So to see where it kind of
collapses on itself.
SETH ROGEN: That would
be very meta.
I mean, I think it's a
truly original movie.
I can honestly say there's no
movie like it, which is not
something that you see a lot
of in Hollywood, I think.
And it just destroys.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah, I think
it's gotten the most laughs
per minute of any movie
we've made.
SETH ROGEN: Yeah, I think in the
theater, it plays better,
honestly, than any of our
other movies ever have.
RYAN GERMICK: It's
a big movie.
There's a lot of big
stuff going on.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Michael Cera.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Michael Cera.
EVAN GOLDBERG: People got to see
what this guy does. it's
fucking crazy.
RYAN GERMICK: And so when he's
impaled, at that point, you
can go and get popcorn, because
it's sort of like
[INAUDIBLE].
EVAN GOLDBERG: No, you need that
app that tells you when.
We should find out what moment
they've deduced.
There's an app that tells you
when to go to the washroom.
SETH ROGEN: It's probably in the
montage where we're bored.
RYAN GERMICK: When it gets all
new wave for a second.
SETH ROGEN: The bored montage.
RYAN GERMICK: What
about you, Craig?
Give us your best pitch here.
CRAIG ROBINSON: I do a duet
with Rihanna in the movie.
RYAN GERMICK: That's true.
SETH ROGEN: That's true.
EVAN GOLDBERG: To "Take
Your Panties Off"
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yes, to "Take
Your Panties Off."
RYAN GERMICK: And you do a duet
with Snoop Dogg on the
soundtrack.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Yes,
Snoop Dogg--
Snoop Lion.
We did a remix to "Take
Your Panties Off."
And it's out now.
EVAN GOLDBERG: You can make love
to the song right now.
CRAIG ROBINSON: It'll be
on the soundtrack.
Yeah, we did it pretty
much for this movie.
I don't even know how
that came about.
[INAUDIBLE], I guess.
SETH ROGEN: It was
our dumb idea.
EVAN GOLDBERG: It was
CRAIG ROBINSON: And first--
I mean, yeah, and they
made it happen.
And we went in the studio
with Snoop Dogg.
I've never been higher
in my life.
RYAN GERMICK: Just
from contact?
Just like--
EVAN GOLDBERG: No.
SETH ROGEN: No.
CRAIG ROBINSON: No.
I participated.
SETH ROGEN: Ferocious
direct intake.
EVAN GOLDBERG: But all the
legends, Snoop Lion is the
legend that he is.
It's true.
CRAIG ROBINSON: He's a very
wise leader, that he is.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, and like a
Pop Warner football coach.
He's a grounded individual.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Yeah, the only
time he seemed upset with me
the whole time was he asked
if I like to go for walks.
And I said, not really.
And he's like a very-- he's a
dad and likes to go for walks.
And every now and then, he
comes and gets stoned and
makes an incredible song.
RYAN GERMICK: Cool.
Well, you guys made an
incredible movie.
SETH ROGEN: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: Everybody should
go out and see it.
June 12, "This is the End."
But it's more of like a
quarter period for you guys.
You're going to keep going.
EVAN GOLDBERG: This is
just the beginning.
SETH ROGEN: We keep going.
RYAN GERMICK: When you're
80, you'll making the
80-year-old--
EVAN GOLDBERG: We're not
living that long.
Keep saying that.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Hi,
80-year-old Craig.
RYAN GERMICK: Cool.
Well, again, it's a real
pleasure and honor to speak
with you guys.
Thanks so much for coming.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Thanks
for having us.
CRAIG ROBINSON: Thank you all.
EVAN GOLDBERG: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]